Hola de nuevo, una vez más aquí tenemos
una espeluznante, súper espeluznante expresión,
una vez más veré si puedes simplificar esto, te daré
un poco de tiempo para que lo hagas, así que...
bueno entonces es una expresión mucho
más alocada que las anteriores
que hemos hecho hasta ahora.
Tenemos "y", tenemos "xy", tenemos "x" cuadrada,
"xy"más, tenemos "y" cuadradas...
Entonces bueno, está genial esto, aquí habrá
algo de tentación porque ves las "y" y ves
la otra "xy"aquí y tal vez tú digas,
oh bueno, yo puedo sumar este "-3y" y este "4xy"
de alguna manera, porque bueno, ves
una "y" y ves otra "y" en el "xy",
pero es importante darse cuenta que una "y" es diferente
que una "xy", piénsalo como si fueran números,
si "y" es igual a 3, si "x" es igual a 2 entonces
"xy" es igual a 6, así que son muy diferentes.
Y aunque veas la misma letra aquí, no puedes
sumarlas o restarlas no, porque no son términos
semejantes que es lo que estamos viendo en
este video, términos semejantes.
Y es muy diferente "y" al cuadrado y "y" es
muy diferente a "xy", ahora ya con esto dicho,
veamos si hay algo que podamos simplificar.
Primero pensemos en este término en el término
con "y", entonces tenemos aquí "-3y"
y ¿tenemos más términos con "y"?
Claro que sí... claro que sí, tenemos aquí
"2y", ahora lo voy a reordenar,
tenemos aquí "-3y" más "2y" y ahora...
ahora vamos con el término "xy".
Vemos todos los términos "xy", tenemos aquí
éste, más "4xy", entonces lo voy a circular,
más "4xy"...
y después tenemos por acá, "-4xy", entonces "-4xy".
Ahora a lo que sigue,
¿tenemos términos con "x" cuadrada?
¡Claro! tengo aquí el "-2x" cuadrada por lo tanto
aquí tengo "-2x" cuadrada
y ¿tengo algún otro término semejante a "x" cuadrada?
¡Claro! aquí tengo este término, "3x" cuadrada entonces
más "3x" cuadrada y bueno veamos,
¿tengo algún término con "x"?
Tal parece que es el único término que tienen
"x", entonces tengo aquí solamente más "2x"
y también solo tengo un termino que tiene a "y" al cuadrado, así que aquí pongo más "y" al cuadrado.
Y todo lo que he hecho hasta el momento es
reordenar esta expresión y lo puse con sus
respectivos colores basado en el tipo de término
que tenemos,
ahora deberá ser un poco más sencillo, así que hagamos esto.
Si yo tengo -3 de algo...
Si yo tengo 2 de algo y le resto 3 de ese algo,
¿cuánto me queda?
Me queda -1 de ese algo, cierto, entonces
yo puedo escribirlo como "-1y"
o simplemente lo puedo escribir como "-y".
Otra manera de hacer esto sería, bueno, vemos
el coeficiente.
El coeficiente aquí es -3 y acá es 2, entonces
ambos tienen el mismo término "y",
haciendo la cuenta tenemos -3 más 2 es -1, entonces
yo pongo "-1y" o simplemente pongo "-y",
es lo mismo, esto se simplifica a eso, así que
ahora vamos con los términos... el término "xy"...
Si yo tengo "4xy" y le quito "4xy",
¿cuántos "xy" me quedan?
Me quedan 0 "xy", nada.
Así que podrías decir, la suma de los coeficientes
4 y -4, entonces 4 más -4, esto te da 0,
tenemos 0 "xy" y de cualquier manera esos
dos se cancelan,
así que tengo 4 de algo y quito 4, me quedan... nada.
Aquí no tenemos término "xy", puedo escribir
yo 0 "xy" pero bueno, no tiene... no tiene sentido,
está de más hacerlo, no es necesario,
así que por acá tenemos los términos "x"
cuadrada, ahora vamos con esos, -2 más 3
es 1, entonces tenemos "1x" cuadrada,
que es lo mismo que "x" cuadrada.
Otra manera de pensar en esto me es, bueno,
si yo tengo "3x" cuadrada y le quito 2 de
esos "x" cuadrada, entonces me queda "x" cuadrada
simplemente, aquí pongo más "x" cuadrado
y ahora tenemos "-y" más "x" al cuadrado,
a estos términos no hay algo que se les pueda hacer,
no se pueden simplificar, entonces simplemente nos queda, más "2x" cuadrada más "y" al cuadrado.
Y hemos terminado.
Tal vez aquí tú tengas una respuesta en
otro orden, pero si tienes estos cuatro términos,
en cualquier orden que esté, no importa,
estás en lo correcto.
Así que felicidades.